[音楽]
こんにちはまなび社長です
梅雨に来ましたエレベーター企画
というわけでいよいよ私はじめしゃちょー
3億円のお家にエレベーターが実装された
ということでエレベーターを使った動画
撮れるようになりましたいきなり
そのエレベーターを作った企画なんです
けれども
佐野県のうちに一応4階建てになってて4
カ所エレベーターが止まる場所があります
1階2階で3階を1回行ってこう部屋の形
とかも出た瞬間が大きな
濃厚は無理だ今エレベーターの中なんです
けれどもエレベーターってちっちゃい部屋
が移動するわけですよいろんな海を
[音楽]
エレベーターとかいろんな貝を移動する
わけですよここが2回
ここが1回
ここが3回ここが4回今見てもらったら
分かる通り開いた時の世界が全部違うん
ですけれどももしもしこの1階から4階の
切られた先の世界が全て
同じ世界だったらそしてその世界が
[音楽]
闇に染まっていたらどう思うんでしょうか
はいというわけで今回の企画は
エレベーターの外の世界が
全て闇の異世界になっていただくとやって
みたいと思います
世界一黒い布を買いました世界一黒いので
1回2回3回4回このエレベーターに
出入りできると
合計4カ所あるんですけどもこの4つとも
全てを
漆黒の全く反射しない黒い素材の布で
覆い隠すと1回も2回も3回も4回5個下
に行っても真っ黒の世界しか
[笑い]
第2回3回4回どのボタンを押して出よう
としても全て出口がふさがっている
エレベーターから出られないそして触れる
ものの全く反射しないし
漆黒の壁完全に闇の異世界に閉じ込められ
てしまったって思うわけですよそりゃ怖い
でしょうねなんかそういうのあるじゃない
ですかエレベーターでなんかこう異世界に
行くみたいな都市伝説それ
僕について起こしますというわけで今日は
エレベーターから出れなくなって
暗黒の異世界に閉じ込められてしまうって
きりやってみたいと思いますでどうなっ
ちゃうんだろう全くわかんないですけどで
は楽しみです
木の板を準備しました
早速作っていきましょう
いきます
絶対ダメ
[音楽]
光を外しない漆黒の板4枚準備しました
めっちゃ黒いこれを
扉に押し付けて
照れなくします
[音楽]
回僕自分に乗ってみますねまず1回行って
みます今4回以外には全部漆黒の部屋に
なってると思うのでどうなってんだろう1
回いきます
[音楽]
完全に漆黒です
月2回行こっかな2回
ちょっとあと
結構やばいぞこれ
[音楽]
回いきます
階2階3回光が反戦出国の異世界に行って
きましたあとはターゲットの金が4階から
乗るので
撮った瞬間4回押し下げば完全に全てが
エレベーターの外の世界が全て
漆黒の異世界になるということです
早速やっていきましょう
[音楽]
はい1回来てもらっていい1回その最速で
お願いします最速で
俺階段で行くかなどっちが先か競争だ
オッケー
です
[音楽]
[拍手]
えっ
1回だよねここ
[音楽]
から回数わかんなくなったあれ1回じゃ
ない
[音楽]
あれ
え待って
えっ
助けて壊れた
開いた
え1回じゃんどう見ても
回嫌いのかこれ
え
2階2階行きます2回行きますよ
[音楽]
鳴る
しまったここもかっちきしょ2回もかよ
ここもかっち来た2回もかよ
階だ3回
ここも家畜小屋
エレベーターから降りれるよ助けて
[音楽]
4回戻る
終わった
終わったマジで
終わったマジでおい
待って
本当に
なんでなんでこんな嫌なことするのなんで
こんなこと嫌なことするの降りれない
じゃんそれはきっとあれだ
都市伝説の
異世界に繋がるエレベーターだろ
4回
すごいな
[音楽]
楽チンですねーもう4階です
どうすんのこれ
ダブル
[音楽]
えどうしたらいい
やばいやばい1回下がります
いいどういうこと
[音楽]
このエレベーター4階1階2階に3回4階
に登ると思うんですけども
全部の扉が
光を吸収しない
漆黒の壁で
異世界になってるドッキリです中二
秒間半端ないですね4階に行ってみよう4
階は行きました
[音楽]
いいですか
漆黒だから突き破れないはずだ突き破れ
ないですよねちょっとやってみますいき
ます
やば
次は最後だ2回です2回
全力で突破したいですね
相当硬いですか
一緒に行きます
よはい
せーの
[音楽]